بالفعل لا يزال هذا الشارع شارع
ملفا حيث تم اعتقال شخص وهناك صور لهذا
لعمليه الاعتقال تم صعقه قبل ان قبل ان
يتم يعني قبل ان يتم القبض عليه ومن ثم
نقله الى احد مراكز الشرطه للتحقيق معه
ايضا بحسب الاخبار بان
يعني هناك
الحوادث التي اودت بمقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
واصابه ثلاثه اخرين احد هؤلاء المصابين هو
الان في حاله خطره مما قد يزيد من عدد
ضحايا هذه الحواجب الثلاثه التي وقعت في
مساحه
بوسط واطراف مدينه
نوتينغام ايضا بحسب الشرطه او قائده شرطه
بان
المراحل التحقيق لا يزال في بدايته ومن ثم
تريد معرفه او الفريق المحقق في هذه
الحوادث المختلفه منذ قليل اعلنت رئيسه
الشرطه ان الوحده الارهاب ايضا دخلت معهم
على خط التحقيق في هذه الحوادث رغم انه في
ساعات الاولى كان هناك استبعاد لفرضيه
الارهاب هل من معلومات تفصيليه حول الامر
في حقيقه ان الشرطه مكافحه الارهاب تشارك
في هذا التحقيق مع شرطه ولكن لا تقود
عمليه التحقيق في هذه المرحله الاوليه الا
اذا تبين ان هناك دوافع تدعو جهاز مكافحه
الارهاب يعني ان تتسلم وتقود هذا التحقيق
في عمليه الحوادث المختلفه ايضا بالنسبه
للشرطه الشرطه هنا تقول بان كلما كانت
لديها معلومات سيتم الكشف عنها لساكنه
هذه المدينه وايضا لعامه الناس حتى يعرفوا
بالضبط ما جرى في ساعات المبكره هناك شخصا
تم طعنهم
يعني ليس بعيدا من هذا الشهر حيث اتواجد
بالاضافه الى شخص ثالث اخر في شارع مختلف
تماما وجد مقتولا وبالتالي الشرطه حتى
الان تربط بين جميع هذه الحوادث ولكن
الدوا وهذا الشخص الذي يعتقد انه تم
مداهمه بين ليس بعيدا من المكان الذي
وجدت فيه وجدت فيه وجدت فيه يعني عمليه
عمليتي القتل شخصين لكن بالطبع
التفاصيل الكامله يعني لدينا تفاصيل ولكن
لا نعرف ما هي الدوافع لهذا الشخص الذي
ارتكب هذه الاحداث في ساعات مبكره وخاصه
وان ليست هناك حركه يعني مزدحمه لكن
بالنسبه لهذا الشارع حيث اتواجد يعني
الحركه يعني تبدو طبيعيه للغايه لكن
الشارع
شوارع التي وقعت فيها هذه الحوادث تم
اغلاقها واغلاق بعض الشوارع المؤديه اليها
وبالتالي الشرطه لا تزال تحرس يعني هذه
الشوارع بانتظارك بانتظار ان ان تنهي